whoa look it's ufo
it's going at light speed
oh i need to follow it no
that's freaking amazing
that is amazing
oh hello oh you got us in the middle of
making a making of welcome to the part
two of the prison behind the scenes in
this one we're gonna cover a lot of the
things we weren't able to cover in the
first one to start things off we're
gonna show you guys a lot of the behind
the scenes footage that we've got we'll
show you how the shots we planned turned
into
real shots okay all right so you guys
have just taken these guys down
you are you look to each other briefly
but then you also realize there are
people with guns that are about to shoot
at you
and what your first reaction is get
behind cover and action
do she kicks the pistol over to you um
everyone basically stands there just
make sure their guns are about to work
lines happen she goes over there blind
fires
and then uh we'll get your cutaways in a
second
and then that way
and
action
before we do this i just wanted to tell
you i know
ready
go
go for it
[Music]
what are you guys doing killing people
well we're shooting at people
we're trying to make a terrible shot
grand theft prism there's a bit of
controversy there i think it's on your
relationship status we didn't do our
homework together we we created separate
stories and when they came together we
were like oh i thought this was much
deeper then
no
no she hates me
we're about two months from breakup i
think
because i'm going to take the prism and
i'm going to teleport to a strip club
because i can
i'm out i'm done done tired of you
[ __ ]
i
need
wide shot here of my laser and jimmy
goes just off to the side he goes out of
frames basically we just reset the
camera angle to right here
and jimmy goes forward and we just get
the lasers
it's extremely important to have it
stylish like that okay so then
what we got is shot nessa she doesn't
roll over onto this side
get a shot of her coming up
i want to get it just an
over-the-shoulder shot of her spraying
receive the location we literally just
see one if we see him start running
you get a shot of him dying
[Applause]
your gun isn't aimed at him yet your
your back is up against the cover
because you didn't expect them then you
try and quick draw him
he kills you like yeah and then he's but
then he puts his gun down and it because
more guard starts going in that's it
also a lot of you guys were wondering
what's up with all your cool costumes
and props how do you make them well one
thing the wire you see here this is
called e-l-wire it's really sweet and it
glows in the dark you see it on a lot of
like dance
performers and crap like that and also
pretty much all the troopers and guys
they're almost all outfitted with
airsoft gear and all this stuff we got
from ebike because they're really rad
dudes and
all airsoft guns are awesome
well i know you guys learned something
in there if you guys have any questions
or comments leave a comment below send
us a twitter tweet or a facebook face or
send us an email that always works too
who knows twitter's our tweets are
cooler yeah
also before i forget we're posting some
awesome concept art from prism on our
facebook page right now so you should go
there and check it out
you